welcome to this video playing hmm Jaso
rolla yeah and playing a bit of a for
getting some the right Ian yeah the
Russell limo yeah let's take them to go
for that setup I played a bit of that
with with black at some point and I
never found it to be particularly great
well black is solid is not yeah having
much fun in this kind of position at
least when I played it it never felt
like much fun I probably didn't play it
well many good players some do do play
like that so it's not a bad line for
black or anything so I'm trying to
prepare for F for ya now or just 92
earlier maybe hear that first and then f
form
yeah I really had those kind of
positions and I always thought that
white is better at least a bit just
doesn't feel very very threatening for
watches why it's got a very year sound
porn structure yeah it's got a very
sound porn structure and I never really
knew what blacks plan was do I go like
g4 or something I wonder about that
night where should that night go if i go
to g4 he will simply take it and that's
not really helping
yeah maybe something with chief form
okay well yeah I've got night h4 right
age for ideas h6 surprised me a bit i
didn't expect that move okay well that
that should be nice out with their file
here so h1 not yeah probably is helpful
gaining a little bit of space there
yeah h5 or not that's an interesting
interesting question yeah I think it did
that help form actually gaining more
space ideas being Queen f3 and then e
five if five now is a threat yeah he had
to move this and like if I go in five
d 5 King to g7 this is just about
defending
okay the Queen I wanted to go with the
Queen I left higher but he always has
rookie five so that wasn't a good idea
I have no clear way forward yeah it's
nice but probably Howard said okay that
Queen g43 was kind of useless and I
admitted but I really couldn't I
couldn't find a good way forward okay
the end games are still nice for what so
I don't mind that year only issue could
be time so this for rook and five will
get five now
I dsm-5 it's not reacting to that at all
on here pawn takes rook f64 Luke g6
that's pretty dangerous check so look at
five ok can you can check me here
time warning maybe Queen f5 was better
actually
hang
uh yeah I couldn't myself into trouble I
Kenya unbelievable sadly position where
white was just clearly in control
amazing check check check check girl oh
yeah it's a row I mean you can try to
play on time but it will be very risky
to do so I'm as I'm winning the both
pawns there and and I'm winning then so
if it's a question if you can try to win
on time in that seconds um but yes but
that was just very stupid to you have
six here I have to think here for a
moment and see okay I'm moving actually
here with rook takes c6 ah now I didn't
think about that move Queen f5 is the
threat hmm and she I've got queen of aid
to be honest I didn't see that the c6
pawn was that that was a move even that
this wasn't move even yeah I mean I was
right in saying that if I wins I mean I
had the right hunch there but I didn't
say my original intention was this move
but then check the drawers hmm I simply
didn't simply awkward look that this is
a draw with the perpetual and then I
went here to continue to play but Joe
here there's nothing better than this
kind of thing i believe is threatening
Queenie for I don't have a slow mover
prep move or anything so this is
actually just winning for with queen of
five
or queen of a time like this shadows
check all the time check oops let's also
check check check this kind of thing is
going to enter to end it
hmm yeah which is six that wasn't
especially difficult I think however if
he's not if he's not allowing this like
here like rookie six or something he's
probably okay i mean i can continue here
with white white structure is a bit
better so i always have some kind of
justification to you have to try around
but it's probably nothing special if i
go here by the way I'm not threatening
much that's the problem if you can just
do something like this check and
recapture which is totally okay so
nothing here okay well thanks for
watching